are you looking for a show that has Nazi
puppets cockroaches making it with rats
and ravenous attacking buttholes look no
further than Doom Patrol but did I never
mention the sentient teleporting gender
queer Street Vic and I hung out on while
Jane lost her [ __ ] and tried to get
married yes we can't forget that
teleporting gender queer Street Doom
Patrol is an absolutely fantastic show
which may have some of the best
character arcs of any comic adaptation
to date so in this video I'll be
breaking down the ending and taking a
deep dive into how our characters went
from zeroes to heroes the last episode
entitled Ezekiel Patrol named after the
cockroach who believes he's God's
messenger follows our heroes after the
big revelation in episode 14 that Niles
Caulder their beloved chief was
responsible for all the tragic events
that changed the course of their lives
forever for a show about superheroes
most of the plot actually revolves
around the characters overcoming their
past and coming to terms with their new
identities we have Larry Trainor a gay
US Air Force pilot who gets fused with a
space anomaly and shuns his friends and
family read afar a washed-up Hollywood
actress who can turn into a hideous blob
cliff steal a philandering ex racecar
driver turned Iron Man Victor a case
Eyeborg a half man half cyborg
struggling with the death of his mother
of which he feels responsible for and
crazy Jane a young woman unable to
control her 64 multiple personalities if
these characters are gonna become a team
and defeat the show's main villain mr.
nobody they'll need to first overcome
their weaknesses and grow as characters
but back to the plot the beginning of
the final episode starts with the team
confronting Niles about the shocking
revelation that he engineered their
tragedies for example he was the one who
set up Larry to get hit by the space
anomaly and was also the one that set up
cliffs car crash which killed his wife
and subsequently turned him into a robot
needless to say the entire team is
pissed and want nothing to do with him
it's tragically ironic that the whole
season surrounds them trying to save
Niles only for them to shun him in the
end mr. nobody doesn't kill them that's
not his goal he wants revenge and what
better way than for all these heroes who
are immortal to live eternity wallowing
in their own self-pity hating themselves
and living in misery we
a brief glimpse of what all their lives
are like in this hell on earth Rita is
an undervalued high school drama teacher
Jane is a junkie
cyborg suffers from nightmares and Niles
lives alone at due manner in essence the
Doom Patrol is doomed to live out the
rest of their lives as miserable
nobodies the fact they have to live this
out forever makes it doubly tragic but
that's what this first season of Doom
Patrol is all about immortality in the
final episode we learn that nas was part
of a program at the bureau of normalcy
called the immortus initiative on the
surface it looks like he just wants to
find a way to be immortal like his lover
oye WA but the real reason is for him to
live longer enough to make sure his
daughter is protected to understand this
we need to go back to episode 10 and
examine douses relationship with oye WA
the mystical Huntress who saved his life
in the northern Yukon this happened all
the way back in 1913 when Niles and his
partner Alastair working then for the
Bureau of oddities were attacked by
wolves
Niles survives and is rescued by oye WA
who becomes his captor and later his
lover he finds out that she's immortal
and becomes fascinated with her staying
by her side and beginning their love
affair
it's only when Alastair finds Niles
years later that he must leave her in
order to protect her if you were to stay
he would risk the bureau of normalcy
finding and capturing her but now we
know a little bit more
oye WA had his child which will later
come to know as Dorothy spinner but
we'll get to that in a bit
Niles locked Dorothy in the dollhouse on
Danny Street to keep her safe from the
bureau and mr. nobody and devoted his
life to finding a way to become immortal
Jane cliff Larry Rita and Cyborg all
became his experiments his way to find a
path to immortality but as we'll find
out these experiments fail these
characters are all broken both
internally and externally Jane can't
control her personalities cliff his
negative man Rita her blob powers cyborg
his grid system and cliff well cliffs a
robot
Niles made them this way and deep down
feels responsible for them hence why he
allows them to stay at due manner and
gives them purpose through the Doom
Patrol
but you think mr. nobody now victorious
would be celebrating his victory nope he
achieved all he had hoped for but now
his drunken himself into a stupor he no
longer has a
purpose he's directionless he's back to
being a nobody
what's a villain to do that's when he's
introduced to Ezekiel the cockroach who
tells him he hasn't finished off Niles
for good if you really want revenge on
him you must take away the one thing he
truly cares about his daughter at the
same time our miserable doomed Patrol is
haunted by chumbawamba's I get knocked
down and I get up again
a fitting song for our ragtag group of
zeros they've been knocked down and if
they're gonna get back up again they'll
need to put their hatred of Niles aside
and band together as a team the song
leads them to do manner where a
distraught Niles informs them that mr.
nobody has trapped his daughter and
Danny the street inside a painting and
he needs their help to save them
it's here that Cliff is like no effing
way after all Niles orchestrated the
death of his wife so that he could use
cliff as his next experiment it's pretty
messed up
but Jane is the one to agree saying
she's not doing it for Niles but for
Danny and the girl and it makes sense
that Jane is the one to say this her
whole multiple personality disorder was
brought upon as a child who wasn't
protected her personalities act as a
shield protecting her from her abusive
father I'm sure in some way Jane feels
this need to be there for a young child
because no one was ever there for her
the Doom Patrol transports into the
painting only to find out that the
cockroach and Admiral whiskers have
ballooned into giant kaiju like
creatures if they're gonna put a stop to
them mr. nobody and save now his
daughter they'll need a plan
it's--at peeping toms perpetual cabaret
we learned that mr. nobody has been
overthrown by Ezekiel and that he used
the beard hunters powers to track down
Niles his daughter he drinks himself
silly but it's Rita who gives him a pep
talk she says it's better to be a nobody
than nothing and convinces him to have a
comeback and use his power of narration
to convince Ezekiel to make out with
Admiral whiskers yes this plan is
absolutely bonkers but so is the show
Rita cyborg and cliff make their way
into the cockroaches stomach while Lyra
uses his negative man energy to open a
portal back to the real world in the
dollhouse Jane and Niles rescue Dorothy
when Larry transports all them back to
the real world
leaving the beard hunter and mr. nobody
in the white space
the white space referring to the white
space found in between comic book panels
since cockroaches can survive powerful
blasts of radiation Rita cyborg and
cliff are able to withstand the blast so
can Larry because he is radioactive
himself but how did Niles Dorothy and
Jane magically transport into the
stomach of the cockroach the answer may
have something to do with Dorothy and
her special powers in the comics Dorothy
spinner is a character who has the
ability to bring imaginary beings to
life she also has a facial deformity
that gives her the appearance of an
eight this could also be why we never
actually see her face in the final
episode her name is a nod to Dorothy
Gale from The Wizard of Oz and she even
wears the same clothing in pigtails
Dorothy does at the very end the
ape-like face would also work with her
mother being an ancient hairy godlike
woman but unlike the comics it appears
this Dorothy spinner has far greater
powers when mr. nobody is confronted by
Niles he says that the girl is quote an
adorable chip off the old block and that
she was the woman who enlarged Ezekiel
and Admiral whiskers in episode 10 we
also see that when the beard hunter
found Dorothy he was attacked by the
same monster oh yay was someone more
than a century earlier so it's likely
whatever powers oye WA had had been
transferred to the daughter in the
comics Dorothy later becomes a member of
the Doom Patrol and this might happen in
the show as well it will be interesting
to see if season two will pick up right
after the events of season one or a few
years later when Dorothy is older and
better able to harness her powers this
leaves us with what is next for Doom
Patrol will they remain together or go
back to their separate ways yes they did
save Dorothy but will their hatred for
Niles keep them apart my guess is that
with mr. nobody still in the picture
pardon the pun something will bring our
Patrol back together this show was a
totally fun ride and the best DC comic
adaptation I've seen yet and here's
hoping for a season two thanks for
watching everyone please make sure to
LIKE and subscribe and give me your
thoughts on the season below you can
also follow me on Twitter at pings story
YT I'll be coming out with more videos
so stay tuned and remember daddy loves
you very much